He said he's feeling
tinges of, like, game time.
I think there's a
chance he goes tomorrow.
There are remote
cameras because we
want to stay out of Alex's line
of sight when he's doing it.
OK, everybody knows what to
do if something goes wrong.
Josh, just to confirm,
who should Mikey call?
The easiest thing
would just be 9-1-1,
and that wheel will
get kicked into gear,
and tell them what you know.
A climber.
Yeah.
All right.
No mistakes tomorrow.
I'm worried that tomorrow's
going to be, like, you know?
Like, Alex's existence
will be over.
I was Like, oh, I have to be
prepared for that outcome.
And I have to realize that
that is a real possibility.
Oh, god.
It'll be enough [inaudible]
Remember when
you said you were
going stand up for my goodbye?
Oh is it time?
- Yeah.
- Oh.
But you don't
have to stand up.
But you have to sit up.
[exaggerated groan]
[inaudible] is laughing.
No, now you're never gonna go.
[kissing]
Mm.
OK, drive safe.
Ciao.
[inaudible]
See you later.
I mean, I didn't
ask her to leave.
I mean, I would never
But, you know, I
think she kind of
understands that it's probably
easier for me if she's gone.
I don't-- the whole, like,
saying goodbye thing,
I'm like, I'll probably
see her in, like,
five days or something.
It's not like goodbye.
It's just goodbye
for a few days.
You know.
I mean, there's just that,
like, weird thought of,
like, don't fricking let that
be our last hug, or whatever.
You know, like, I shouldn't
be having that thought.
[sob]
Of, like, what if
something happens.
Like, what if I
don't see him again?
So you're like, why do
you want to do this?
Like, it's this
totally crazy goal.